You know what? You almost never see a
Christian psychopath trying to help a
Muslim narcissist.
Yeah, I'm talking about me and you,
Muhammad Hijab.
Now that you're being exposed by one of
your ex-wives for your abuse of women
and for enlisting the help of dozens of
your fellow Dagandists to cover up what
you did and for lying to your followers
and for blackmailing a shake and for
trying to discredit your victim by
spreading a photoshopped screenshot and
an AI generated fake confession. You're
rapidly becoming a liability to the Dawa
community. Your dear friend Ali Dawa
lied for you and this led to him being
exposed for treating Muslim women like
prostitutes. Now he's known as the MUT
guy.
>> Oh, okay. It looks cool though.
>> Are you the guy that's in the mut
marriage? Is that you?
>> Uh, no. Maybe maybe it's you.
>> Muslims at Speaker's Corner are getting
blasted for helping you abuse a Muslim
woman.
>> If you have dishonored them, then let
them go.
>> Like how you dishonored Muhammad Job's
second wife.
Hashim, do not speak to the audience,
especially about women cuz you abuse
women.
>> Hey, by the way, dog, come here.
>> I remember we joined your line about
this dog.
>> Yeah. Hashim,
>> come dog.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Doggy doggy dog.
>> Is that how you treat women?
>> I treat you dog.
>> Okay.
>> Are you a dog?
>> No. You're a woman of Jesus dog.
>> No one in the Dawa community can feain
ignorance about you because you've been
showing your true colors for years.
>> You can lie to your your spouse in this
situation. The issue of this is that
>> but can can they lie in the context of
for example if one says I sense that
you've got a second wife can he says can
he say no I don't
>> yes he can you can say that
>> he can say that I
>> I personally believe this is what white
lies
>> it doesn't have to be white it can be a
black line
>> the people who the women who take it the
best are the revert sisters from my
experience of observing the situation
you know I found
And now, because of your ego and your
terrible choices, you've been exposed
and humiliated by a woman you abused and
lied about. Your fellow Dawagandists
can't even open their mouths without
being condemned for being associated
with you. And YouTubers are turning this
into a huge Muhammad hijab pylon. Not a
pylon in the zut sense, but in the oh my
goodness, this guy is imploding and he's
bringing all of Dawa down with him
sense. I've obviously joined the chorus
of voices against you. But I'm in the
chorus for a different reason. Most
people are cheering for your downfall
because they just can't stand you or
because they love to see DA collapsing
or because they want to help women who
are being abused by the Dawa Diddy Club.
I share the goals of demolishing DA and
protecting victims of abuse. But I'm
also here to help you, the abuser, the
manipulator, the egoomaniac.
And I may be the only person on the
planet right now who can help you
because I know exactly what you're going
through. You poor poor man. Let me tell
you a story about the worst day of my
life. The worst day of my life was not
the day my grandma died or the day my
son died or the day my mother died or
the day my father died or the day my
brother died or the day Nibil died. It
wasn't the day I went to a mental
hospital or the day I went to jail or
the day I went to prison. Nothing like
that. Why? Because as awful as
antisocial personality disorder is, it
comes with an amazing ability to endure
an endless array of bad events and
circumstances without being phased even
slightly.
But there's one way to seriously hurt a
psychopath. There are lots of ways to
hurt a narcissist because narcissists
are super fragile. But the most
devastating way to hurt a narcissist
happens to be the same way to hurt a
psychopath.
Now, for the worst day of my life, it
was towards the end of the first quarter
of 8th grade. I don't remember what I
was doing, but teachers kept sending me
to the principal's office. One day, I
got called to the principal's office
again, and the woman at the desk told me
to go into the conference room.
I walked into the conference room, and
there seated around the table were the
principal, the vice principal, the
guidance counselor, four or five of my
teachers, my mom, my mom's boyfriend,
and my grandmother.
And I knew instantly that all of these
people being together in the same room
was really, really bad because I acted
like a different person for different
people in that room. You see, people
were always feeding me information about
what they liked and what they didn't
like. If I wanted someone to like me, I
would pick up on what they liked. And I
would do that more and more until I was
their favorite person in the world. If I
didn't like someone, I would pick up on
what they didn't like, and I would do
that more and more until I was their
ultimate nightmare.
So over time, I developed custom
personalities for different people. Now,
what happens when all these people
who've all been experiencing a different
version of David Wood get together in
the same room and start sharing stories
about what David is like around them.
I'll tell you what happens. They went
around the room and the same thing
happened over and over again.
A teacher would say, "Here's what David
did in my class." And then half the
people in the room would look at me
confused.
"David did that, David?"
Then someone else would describe
something I did, good or bad, and half
the people in the room would again turn
and look at me like, "He did what,
David?"
Eventually, my grandma, who thought I
was an angel because I acted like an
angel around her, she locked her eyes on
me and declared,
"David sounds like a chameleon."
Then, as they continued sharing stories,
they kept calling me chameleon, which
didn't help them because it made me feel
like a cool super villain. But the
damage was done. They figured out what I
was doing. They figured out what I was.
They realized I couldn't be trusted.
At the end of that devastating little
meeting, the vice principal gave me a
choice. He said, "David,
you can either stay here or you can
transfer to another school.
If you stay here, the next time I see
you in this office, I'm going to expel
you. If you transfer to another school,
I won't tell them anything about you and
you can get a fresh start.
I chose the fresh start. I switched
schools, not because I was worried about
being expelled, but because I wanted to
get as far away from these people as
possible. They had finally seen right
through me. And they would have always
been suspicious of everything I did,
good or bad.
So, why was that day about as close to
traumatic as a day could get for me?
Well, when you're able to manipulate the
people around you, make them think what
you want them to think, you feel
powerful, you feel superior, the people
around you are like puppets to you.
You're the puppet master. You're in
control. And they don't even realize it.
You're the mastermind.
That feels good.
But the moment they understand what
you're doing, that feeling of power is
instantly stripped away, leaving you
exposed, naked, and defeated.
Sound familiar, Muhammad Hijab? It's
what you're going through right now.
You built your life on a foundation of
manipulation and deception. You dupe
people into doing what you want. You
dupe women into marrying you. and then
you ruin their lives. You dupe your
fellow Dagandists into helping you
manipulate and deceive everyone around
you. You dupe your followers into
thinking that you're doing this for
Islam and not for yourself.
Feels good being able to dupe so many
people, doesn't it? That now you're
being exposed. Your power is being
stripped away.
and you don't know what to do because
you don't know any other way of living.
So, you're going to keep using the same
manipulation tactics, the very tactics
that got you into this mess. And the
more your tactics fail because people
are catching on, the more desperate and
confused and miserable you're going to
become.
I know because I didn't stop
manipulating people when I got exposed
in 8th grade. I was just more careful
about it. I sharpened my skills. I
became an even worse person.
In order to actually change, you need a
completely different way of thinking.
Psychologically, hijab, you view
yourself as the center of the universe.
You're the star and you want everyone
else revolving around you like planets.
Everything you do is meant to get more
people revolving around you. When people
break away from you and escape, you
become enraged and you try to force them
back into orbit.
In your mind, people refusing to do what
you want is the problem. But that's not
the real problem. People shouldn't do
what you want because you're a
narcissistic lying control freak.
The real problem is how you view people.
Human beings are created in the image of
God. They're not supposed to revolve
around you.
You have to stop viewing them as planets
revolving around you, the star, and
start viewing them as other stars in a
shared galaxy. You can view material
objects, phones, computers, cars, as
satellites revolving around you. But you
have to stop viewing people that way. It
won't be easy. I can tell you from
experience. I had to be broken.
And it is hard to break me.
But as awful as it was being broken,
it's exactly what I needed. It wasn't
just good for everyone around me. It was
good for me.
I needed a real fresh start, not just a
new school with new victims. So, as
you're sitting there panicking about
what to do, flailing about, desperately
trying to get your people back under
your control, just know that what's
happening right now, no matter how
painful it may seem, is for your own
good.
When all of your tactics have failed,
and they will fail,
when your bag of tricks is empty, man up
and follow Jesus, the rightful center of
the universe.
Or you can keep bailing water from the
sinking ship that is the SS Muhammad
Hijab
and see where that takes you.
[Music]
You proud on that. You just backfired on
me. You proud on that. You proud on
that. You proud on that. You just
backfired on me. This is a powerful
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.